bonjour alex rivière merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous ce matin dans
la matinale d'air france vous
représentez des parents d'élèves mais
vous allez soutenir encore une fois les
les syndicats d'enseignants cet après
midi dans la rue
la difficulté c'est que la nomination la
semaine dernière à apporter
effectivement soit autre chose on n'est
toujours pas
comment dire dans les pures par rapport
à ce qu'il faudrait que les choses
soient faites sur les terrains les
parents continuent à vivre une situation
qui est quand même extrêmement chaotique
et on n'a pas de réponse notamment pour
les épreuves de bac antiquités les
trajets professionnels qui vont
commencer au mois d'avril oh là on
commence à arriver vers la fin de
l'année avec des échanges et des examens
si ce n'est pas le cas il se rapproche
et l'éternelle question continue à se
poser et on n'en vit à la troisième
année on va trouver les mêmes questions
le ministre n'a pas répondu encore sûr
mais a promis en tout cas que des
mesures seraient prises pour pour ses
examens vous en attendez quoi
concrètement
les élèves que les élèves terminent leur
année scolaire le mieux possible et si
j'étais si nous n'arrivons pas à nouer
un dialogue ou alors nous l'avons poussé
pour que les et les rectorats on
accompagne également la démarche à
savoir que les les instances de lycéens
puissent donner leur avis du ce qu'on
veut gagner ce texte a calé les jetons
qui ont eu le programme donc il devait
recevoir dont ils sont prêts pour passer
cet examen l'autre on commence seulement
par exemple à à recevoir l'enseignement
qu'ils n'ont pas lu depuis le début de
l'année et on est toujours ce qu'on fera
une structure elles toutes façons de
remplacements d'enseignants
il ya des enseignants qui ne sont pas
arrivés sur poste encore depuis le mois
de septembre on commence et une place de
quatrième ne puisse pas voir espagnol
anglais des classes de terminale
physique-chimie sa façon on est dans une
discontinuité en certaines personnes
avaient été embauchées dernière à peu
près un petit peu en amont par rapport à
cette scène avec talent et de l'année le
problème c'est qu'ils ont été remerciés
au mois de juin donc on n'a pas pu
préparer la rentrée parce que quand vous
êtes trop merci au mois de juin pensez y
est car vous trouviez de quoi financer
votre les à chaque métier d'avocat
fédérateur août donc les gens ne sont
pas organisés autrement résultat les
courses mais là dessus nous n'y
arriverons pas là dessus le gouvernement
a promis justement de le déblocage de
personnel pour pallier à ce manque
d'enseignants il a promis également des
ffp2 pour pour les enseignants les
mesures annoncées la semaine dernière ne
vous ont pas convaincus vous non plus on
donc parents d'élèves l ont convaincu
certains syndicats d'enseignants
je pense que les parents d'élèves seront
beaucoup plus convaincu dès lors qu'ils
verront des professeurs devant leurs
enfants parce que on est occupés ya une
semaine mais on est sur un pan de
réaction
n'était pas nous laisser le temps de
réaction la première piste et clame
après tout les réponses immédiates
procès immédiat qu entre temps on a
appris que jean michel blanquer arrêtait
à ibis halal à la veille de ce protocole
sanitaire imposé dans les écoles à la
rentrée en janvier quelle a été votre
réaction
moi je pense que c'est sa vie
personnelle après extrêmement d'un point
de vue
renvoi dit nash extrêmement maladroit
maintenant j'ai envie que marié
l'équipement ils sont tous bonheur
qu'est ce que je voulais vous dites est
ce que il ya urgence à se marier à six
mois de la fin d'un
mandat clair quand anthony l'éducation
nationale s'ajuster par pourra très bien
ses priorités on s'en rend compte et
puis je voulais dire qu'ils n'étaient
que c'est grossier ans un serment en
tant que représentant de la fpq depuis
ça depuis c'est la cinquième année où
j'ai l'impression que quand même que
l'effort aux intermédiaires ont je pense
pour hasni maltraités et jean michel
blanquer retraite est suffisement
extrêmement mal la fcpe alors cet après
midi nouvelle manifestation à l'appel de
certains syndicats qui maintiennent le
cap qui vont réclamer également des
meilleurs salaires vous les soutenez
aussi là dessus
on apprend global géré sur les parkings
du test en public moi je ne comprends
pas je ne comprends pas il ya eu un
grand m de l'éducation qui a été fait ou
on s'est aperçu que finalement c'est une
renégociation salariale
on n'a pas fixé la montagne qui a
accouché d'une souris sont tous en
parlent plus du tout je d'un point de
vue budgétaire on sait qu'il a retiré
les primes spécifiques pour les
personnels ils sont le plus haut le plus
auprès de ne plus longtemps à la journée
auprès de nos élèves qui sont les
accompagnements pour les élèves en
situation de handicap ou à besoins
particuliers ou les surveillantes qui
sont ils sont des éléments sont trouvera
scolarité d'un collège et en dignité de
la personne qui le tue le voile plus de
salle pierre donc aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que vous espérez obtenir de plus
non seulement tu maintiens qu'il dise où
il en est dans ses recrutements ou est
ce qu'il en est dans sélestat capteur de
co2 les purificateurs d'air vous noterez
que c'est ces deux éléments qui sont
tant
qu' on est indispensable en ce moment
sont des choses qui de toute façon au
pouvoir ce serait l'idée il ya toutes
les épidémies ultérieure elles feront
elles elles seront
elles sont traitées à peu près la même
manière en terme de renouvellement d'air
et de toute façon avec là on a un
problème de roulement - mois déjà à mon
époque nous avons les choses très
franchement je joue seront tes limites
mal parce qu'elle a un problème de
ventilation dans les salles de classe
donc et j'en ai parlé avec d'autres et
elle amène donc on a un souci dont on
s'occupe pas depuis au moins cinq
décennies est l'occasion de faire
avancer les choses merci beaucoup alex
rivière d'avoir répondu à nos questions
ce matin en direct sur arte france